let the beat drop it was the world's
greatest spy sleepy night night but then
you turn me into a pigeon you put on
bird meat right now
you kind of bird it yourself
I feel like in general I'm a New Yorker
I see a lot of pigeons I feel like
pigeons in general get a bad rap I mean
is this film going to sort of put
pigeons in a better place in society
yeah absolutely like we saw this movie
we said there's one thing we can
accomplish with this film is to change
the perception of the mighty pigeon now
pigeons are amazing they they've got so
many cool attributes that make them
fantastic spies they you could find them
in every major city around the world and
most people don't take notice of them
they can fly really fast and almost 92
point seven miles an hour they've got
eyes on the side their head so they can
see in 360 degrees which means they can
see your face and their but at the same
time and they can see UV light so they
can see laser detection systems and they
they are the perfect spy you know I this
cast is a giant ensemble a lot of some
superheroes as well people have played
superheroes you know does the film have
that kind of super heroic quality about
it would you say well I think what's
important with our film is you want to
feel the aspiration of a hero right but
at the same time our characters in the
movie don't have superpowers their
superpowers are working together at the
end of the day and that's really the
message of our film is and this despite
being in the world of espionage where
nobody trusts each other these
characters learn to work together and
that's really what could save the day
and we have our very own superhero well
tell us tell us about your character and
who do you play and why was it so much
fun for you well I play a character
named Kimura he's kind of the modern-day
Yakuza mobster and you know he he's a
dark web happy get anything he wants and
he's a very tough you know rough guy but
that's on the exterior we later find out
that you know he's a teddy bear in the
inside and he's very mushy literally
probably you know physically as well and
I think that it was fun to play him
because you could play the both sides of
a character yeah that's very comedic you
know the
but stuff so just to go from one end to
something else and the fact that you
know the most the worst thing that he's
ever done in his life was to be in a
pool you know I kind of said how would
you say this film sort of advances the
spy genre what do we see in this film
when we learn in this film that maybe we
haven't seen another spider well other
than the fact that a pigeon is a star
right well we I mean we love spy movies
I mean it so it was a great opportunity
to go and make one and and the thing
that really attracted both Nick and I to
it is in the world of espionage where
you can't trust anyone to make a movie
that says the more you trust other
people the strong you are there's
another way of doing things was it was a
really interesting challenge but also a
really exciting element to be able to
bring to the storytelling of it that you
know a fly solo character like Lance can
become a better spy by meeting a let's
work together character like Walter
mm-hmm
what was the pitch to Will Smith when
you said okay you're gonna be a spy but
you're gonna be a pigeon what was that
was was he like yeah sure listen when we
initially pitched to Will Smith that
he'd be the world's greatest spy who's
transformed into a pigeon he thought
that was nuts
as he'd say it's ridiculous it's the
most ridiculous thing but what he really
loved was the heart of bringing people
together and really just how that
teamwork can save the world you know as
a lot of families get ready to take you
know go out to the theater over the
holiday season what do you think this
film was going to offer them that's
fresh and different and new and maybe
something that other films that are
coming out are good offer that I mean
this movie it's got the big action it's
exciting but it's funny it's got a lot
of laughs and it's got a lot of heart
and the big thing is hopefully like I
said it's all audience so you the
parents can can laugh at the nods to the
spy genre the kids can have fun with the
pigeons and and the adventure and at the
end of the day it's it's a hopefully an
aspirational story I mean I think
everyone will go into the theater wanted
to be Lance Stirling but come out of it
wanted to be Walter Beckett awesome
you